hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts
and I just check it in on you just
seeing all your weeks going how you
doing oh Jesus that's great I just got
home another long [ __ ] day working my
[ __ ] balls off working work at work
and so I'm knocking this out Wednesday
evening I'm on my way up to [ __ ]
Vancouver Vancouver British Columbia you
know my Bruins are on a West Coast trip
right now I got I caught the the third
period of a great game against Edmonton
man Edmonton so let me tell ya but said
who they got a tough team who let me
tell you that tough team they played
great despite the fact that casseon is
suspended and Connor McDavid is hurt so
we were able to it took us all the way
into overtime to get two points they got
one point they're just a [ __ ] ray I'd
really like that team I like that team a
lot and you know can you really say you
beat the Edmonton Oilers if both those
players are out I don't think he can you
know what I mean one of the best goal
scorers in the league and I don't think
anybody kicks somebody with the skate on
better than Cassie and so I mean I think
we got off easy never see the guy kick
another guy with a skate on it's been
awhile seen it accidentally out but I'm
it was a long time ago there was a Bruin
I just flaked on his [ __ ] name the
[ __ ] was his name I want to say ended up
finishing his career with San Jose it
was this freak play he was in the front
of the net and somebody cross-checked I
want to see the Randy Burgess Steve
Casper in in the chest and hit him so
hard that his his his feet came up and
he basically kicked this guy I can't
believe it can't member his name [ __ ] I
was like 30 years ago kicked him right
in the [ __ ] mouth and the guy ended
up getting a gash
that went like right through his mic his
mouth was closed so the scar was above
his mouth through the lips and then
below his [ __ ] it was like a Freddy
Krueger slash but it was with skates the
[ __ ] was that guy's name Dave Reid
I think was the guy a long time ago a
long time ago at the old Boston Garden
it's still bugging me that I had Don
Gavin on and I found out at the end of
the podcast that he was at the Celtics
games you know from the very beginning
the late 50s when there was nobody there
and it was Bill Russell and Bob Cousy
and all that so I'm definitely next time
I go to Boston I'm gonna try to reach
out to Don Gavin and get him back on and
just talk [ __ ] hope and what it was
like he was like in the Boston Garden I
guess it was still already an old
building but I think he was there when
it was like when I went it was they had
painted the inside like that Bruins
yellow kind of thing and then back in
the day if you see the Bobby Orr a
Mother's Day goal that they had it was
white the inside of it was white so I
don't just all dumb [ __ ] like that I
want to ask him all about that did he
sneak in because I was a big thing that
people knew how to sneak into that venue
and all of that [ __ ] anyway
big went for the Bruins they've won 10
of the last 11 they're just there
they're playing great and tonight you
know like I said you know that was a
hurt slash suspended edmonton team but
you know they pushed us around a little
bit we were pushing back which is good
we got to do more of that we've got to
do more of that because it seems like
they let that go during the during the
playoffs and anyway I'm gonna do some
shows coming up and speaking of shows
one of my favorite comics of all time
and people we did a special with them
all things comedy did Ian Edwards he's
got some stand-up dates she really got
to catch this guy man he's one of the
best out there and he's uh he's gone the
Rodya what's he got coming up he's got
Springfield Missouri February 21st and
22nd Tampa Florida March 12th and the
15th
in Calgary Alberta March 25th and 28th
and this is why you haven't heard of Ian
Edwards because the not only because he
is a brilliant comedian but the man
stinks at the business he sends me this
[ __ ] thing he says upcoming dates
Tampa Florida there's like three [ __ ]
comedy clubs Ian where the [ __ ] oh Jesus
Christ let me look it up do you know you
know I swear to God do you know me
[ __ ] great comics I know who just
stink at the business Ian Edwards live
let's see what we get here there he is
Ian Edwards comedian all right let's see
what happens when we click on let's see
let's just this is the classic it's
classic terrible and [ __ ] this
business in such a [ __ ] brilliant
comedian all right [ __ ] even on his
website Springfield Missouri Tampa let's
see where is he in Tampa oh there it is
side splitters he's still in the Blue
Room in Springfield Missouri February
21st he's at side
Bobby Jules join if I remember correctly
in Tampa Florida March 12th through the
15th he's at the Laugh shop in Calgary
Alberta the March 25th through the 28th
and then he's got the comics lounge in
Melbourne Australia on April 16th and on
Monday April 20th he's in Sydney
Australia at the Sydney Comedy Festival
just a [ __ ] amazing comedian who
needs to learn how to promote himself
goddamn it anyways I love that guy
so that's it all there was a big big
[ __ ] presidential democratic debate
tonight I didn't watch it I watched
hockey instead I did watch a couple of
eclipses and I quickly saw why I didn't
want to watch it because it's just
people yelling at each other I don't
know what you know politics has always
been filthy but at least they used to
listen to each other and talk a little
bit they just [ __ ] sitting there
yelling at each other and then Bloomberg
said that dumb thing that everybody says
you know communism did
work it failed it's just like it's not
the type of government all governments
fail because people run them and people
are pieces of [ __ ] that's what the
problem is it's not socialism it's not
capitalism it's not comedy all those
forms of government would work if
everybody was honest and played by the
rules but nobody does that's what
happens that's why with every [ __ ]
country every [ __ ] form of government
any type of prosperity arena there's a
beginning a middle and an end because
eventually it [ __ ] goes away it
starts off with a great idea you know a
every man for himself or hey let's all
work together whatever the [ __ ] it is it
does well forbid it and then what
happens is is it the people getting
power and then they keep it more and
more power and it gets more and more
corrupt more and more corrupt and it
either fails or people rebel against it
but it is not it is not the former
because people were sitting again go
sitting there going communism failed
it's like capitalism failed capitalism
failed if you [ __ ] look at it
honestly if you [ __ ] sit there and
look at this country and you're gonna
honestly say that it's [ __ ] working I
mean we're all sitting there not looking
at the [ __ ] 20 trillion dollars
iliyan [ __ ] dollars in debt that we
are elephant in the room
we're not looking at the [ __ ] fact
that there's you know a private
corporation prints our money and there's
nothing behind it which is we're all
just [ __ ] driving 19 miles an hour in
the left lane trying to get to our
[ __ ] brass ring before we turn into a
[ __ ] pumpkin that's what the [ __ ] is
going on I think and I don't know [ __ ]
but I can see that coming from a [ __ ]
mile away yeah it's it's I don't know I
don't know and we just keep [ __ ]
doubling down and tripling down on it so
as far as I mic my mics I don't know
what's he trying to say hit bill the
amount of time that I've been alive okay
what has happened to like when I was a
kid like I mean I remember like the
[ __ ] milkman could have a
stay-at-home mom I mean wife right to
watch the [ __ ]
he made enough [ __ ] money and all of
that I don't know what it just all
[ __ ] went away people had good jobs
and there was like a middle class so you
could just you know you weren't broke
you weren't filthy rich but you could
[ __ ] have a house and all of that
[ __ ] he ain't gonna come in come on in
because we have to talk about you
becoming an art dealer here and all of
that is kind of [ __ ] gone away and I
know that there's I guess now the way to
go from being in the middle class to
getting to the upper classes you got to
become like a YouTube star or something
I don't know anyways yeah I'm in way
over my head I'm talking about different
forms of government and acting like I
know what I'm talking about and what's
great is this is a one-person debate so
there's nobody to shout me down here oh
god is that the energy we're gonna bring
here all right we got one microphone
speaking of communism socialism we're
gonna sit here and share it as opposed
to capitalism where you'd have [ __ ]
there you have as many microphones you
could possibly yep and they'd all look
like lollipops and the fat [ __ ] would
try to eat them
Sonia yeah you're into art I'm not into
art you guys speaking to the mic come
over here yes that's right that's
correct so what does that mean like what
what exactly so you invest in art so
when you invest in art yes you take your
money and you say hey you see that art
over there
I want to give you this for that and
then you take that thing all right
and then you stick it on your wall you
okay and then you wait for the person
who painted it to die as far as I can
tell and then you go hey you know that
guy who just died he's never gonna
scribble Dibble on that piece of paper
anymore and I have one that he [ __ ]
drew all over you want to buy it because
the guy's dead he's never gonna draw
again that means this thing's worth
something no I don't I don't think
that's what you do all the time but you
invest in it yes an artist how do you
invest how do you know what is the good
scribbles well I mean ideally you'd have
someone who is familiar with
that world that can help guide you and
sort of curate your tastes and find you
stuff that Senator Hill how do you plan
to build your art collect name who would
you say the top five artists are right
now I'm not that I'm not that smart
so how exactly are you going to invest
in this you seem to know less about art
than I do about forms of government
would that be a broker Nia no and how do
they make their money Nia by telling you
that that scribble Dibble is worth a
bunch of [ __ ] money yeah yeah so you
don't know anything about art you can't
even name the top people who are [ __ ]
who can take a bucket of paint throw it
at a [ __ ] bedsheet who there's a
million [ __ ] teams out there I mean
there's a million [ __ ] hockey players
the NHL I can [ __ ] tell you the top
players well I'm still learning so I
couldn't tell you that right now but I
can tell you what I like and what I
don't like so what point do you say is
this worth buying do you think this
artist has you know I don't know it is
worth investing in whatever their other
oh yes I absolutely do well you're like
the third person who's walked into the
gallery today the clown [ __ ] you need to
understand there's a there's a three oh
snap there's a three prong situation one
you get a piece of art to elevate your
home one secondly to
[Laughter]
[Music]
secondly it's your personal enjoyment of
the piece a piece that speaks to you
something that looks beautiful something
that resonates with you personally are
you doing
Bill Hader doing Keith yeah and thirdly
you know we're setting up our child to
have something so if you know god forbid
you know something happens that's it
that's a piece of when the zombie shows
up she throws the art at them or she is
sold it beforehand and so she can get a
dodge yes that's that's it all right you
know what Nia I'm not gonna question
anymore that sounds like a solid plan he
said sarcastically oh are you being
sarcastic cuz I mean shits already in
the work so you can be sarcastic all day
but it's happening nuts that's not how
this relationship works did you talk
about this morning huh no you are gonna
get a piece art I'm gonna let you buy
this stupid scribble Dibble yeah I think
so are you gonna tell him no all right I
I've been working a lot you definitely
have been so old freckles got confused
on what day today was I thought it was I
thought today which is Wednesday when
we're recording this I thought it was
Tuesday you're right so I was like this
is great I'm gonna work my ass I'm gonna
work my ass off today Tuesday oh the old
second day of the week if you start on
Monday Vicki what is the first day of
the week Sunday it is Sunday I thought
Sunday's a day a rest it is but it's I
think it's supposed to be considered the
start of the week I don't think so cuz
God worked for six days and on the
seventh day he rested
yeah I mean if you're gonna want that
whole thing but I also heard that that
whole thing you know that whole religion
god thing
it's supposed to be Sundays I consider
it Monday but apparently it's actually a
Sunday hey my boy Joel Osteen's coming
out here to Ontario Canada Ontario
Canada Ontario of California I'm tired
Nick come on I want to [ __ ] take an
edible go to that thing with Bert
Kreischer and I just want to sit there
and listen this guy say nothing but
positive [ __ ] for an hour
I'm not hackling I'm not Eklund oh you
won't be heckling but you'll be sitting
there giggling like little schoolgirls
and you're gonna get asked to leave sir
can you please leave you're disturbing
the others everyone be all talk about
when he walked on water man now I won't
exactly hi actually I'm on the road when
he's out here so I can't go but anyway
the man fascinates me okay any performer
that can make enough money to buy their
own [ __ ] arena in their hometown and
sell it out every weekend I don't give a
[ __ ] what he still you gotta respect
that
alright but you know I told you about
how he turned away those people when the
hurricane happened he wouldn't let them
into the church he didn't what those
fatties rollin around his [ __ ]
electric blue carpet he spent all that
money on gotta stop it with the fat [ __ ]
that's not nice
I don't need to stop what do you mean
that's not nice what about my tax
dollars all these people eating bacon
double cheeseburgers being called heroes
and then it's all the money flies out of
my wallet i watch the debates I know
what's goin on every time a fatty eats a
[ __ ] Sunday you and I have to work
Monday to pay for his triple bypass I am
an [ __ ] and you know what but I'm not
out there eating all the ice cream up
excuse me have you seen yourself when we
buy ice cream in this house you hose
that [ __ ] down hose it down and house it
what is it the way people say you hosed
it what is it I don't know talk about
you eating really fast or something like
you house it I don't know
that's something I've heard why I say
all right I don't know I'm not familiar
with that one whenever there is ice
cream in this house you eat the whole
[ __ ] thing in one sitting
yeah but it's like a pint it doesn't
matter you know you showed no yet those
people eat gallons look at me I'm in
shape I'm in my 50s and I still have a
flat [ __ ] stomach act like you're not
a glutton yourself just because you're
skinny doesn't mean that you're not a
[ __ ] gluttonous hey I'm not [ __ ]
booze out and I laid off it okay they
should start [ __ ] pulling these
fatties over and give them a [ __ ] ice
cream breathalyzer and see ma
cookies-and-cream they had trying to be
on your soapbox as if you're some kind
of like model of like health and
moderation cuz you're not so stop it get
back to the story about this morning
wait a minute how come they don't have
road blocks you [ __ ] Girl Scout
cookies the way you just go at those
thin mints you're an ass no I don't I
hate the Thin Mints you do not I've seen
you eat practically an entire sleeve of
them yeah I know cuz I keep waiting for
it to get good and it doesn't Girl Scout
Thin Mints suck you want those [ __ ]
coconut ones you want the coconut ones
you want the Tagalongs the peanut butter
ones with the chocolate on top
peanut butter it belongs on toast not in
[ __ ] cookies I'm sorry what you're
crazy
peanut butter belongs on toast the only
people who know how to make peanut
butter taste good with chocolate are the
wonderful people over at Reese's M&Ms
M&Ms doesn't how to do it you're the
equivalent of peanut butter on toast
you're the most like [ __ ] you think
you're so special
like if peanut butter on toast like big
[ __ ] deal oh I didn't say it was it
gourmet I just says where it belongs
alright anyway can you talk about this
morning I want to talk about fat people
starting to like have the same terror
that booze hounds have when they leave a
bar and get behind the wheel of a car
how many fat people have heart attacks
while driving trucks for Amazon every
month I don't either
but I'm
saying it in a serious tone that will
make people sit up and take notice
ya know you you are you are nobody to
talk about anybody self-control so I
don't want to hear from you
are you talking about every time I lay
off the booze you go Jesus Christ have a
drink
that's because you're annoying and
you're late I'm like can you please just
do something to relax so you're not
bothering me
alright so you at least agree that I've
been working my ass off this month right
of work of myself okay so I thought this
morning was Tuesday morning so I'm like
well cool man
like I'm gonna work my ass off today get
home hang out with my kid my lovely wife
right and then tomorrow I'm just gonna
[ __ ] chill man and then the car's
gonna pick me up and I'm gonna get on a
plane at like 5:00 in the afternoon and
then I woke up this morning at 5:30 in
the morning I was like hey wait a minute
man it's Wednesday and I have to go to
Vancouver where the [ __ ] my passport I
need the pack I gotta go down to this
[ __ ] thing and all blah blah blah
blah blah and all this [ __ ] so I didn't
know what to do so I cuz my show starts
is Thursday night so immediately going
alright I'll change my flight
I don't wanna [ __ ] do that I don't
know blah blah blah so I started packing
and then we tried to find my passport
which of course we could not so I wake
up I'm sleeping soundly also soundly
it's 5:30 in the [ __ ] morning and
this one goes Mia Mia said Nia I'm sorry
do you know where my passport is did you
I don't remember that point I just
remember you going I screwed up I
screwed up I did over tonight and I was
like okay every possible [ __ ] thing
that then could have happened happen
couldn't find the [ __ ] passport and
then
right let me try to help you let me try
to figure it out we looked here and we
looked there we looked everywhere you
had to leave I kept looking you found it
I was at work you mentioned her that you
mentioned messenger it messaging my kid
said messenger messenger do it over and
then I get it and then I get it and then
I get it I got it and then they found
out that the [ __ ] the passport is
gonna expire in the next couple of
months and unless you know unless it's
you can't [ __ ] get on a plane unless
it's [ __ ] six months out it's like
well then it [ __ ] it's already
expired you [ __ ] so I didn't know that
but was funny everybody everybody what I
was working today they all [ __ ] knew
that oh yeah you can't do that I go
since one that goes since forever I go
all right so I guess that's on me
back and forth back and forth long
[ __ ] story short I'm flying up there
tomorrow I'm landing and I'm running
from the [ __ ] Airport worked out
because you were there for me you did
and then you messenger that measurement
messenger I can't say that word and
everything was cool and club soda candy
you and club soda candy [ __ ] team
bill burr making sure that you got what
you needed when you needed it so that
this train can keep or did you just do
what any wife back in the day would have
done before you guys all became victims
slash heroes I mean you basically you
were Wilma Flintstone for one [ __ ]
day well mom coming through the door
where's my Bronto burger you finally had
it [ __ ] prepared and now to pay you
back I got to go buy a [ __ ] something
that doesn't even look like a poodle but
is a poodle you please say that again
first the [ __ ] of all it has nothing to
do with any of that I was being a good
partner to you period point-blank and
has nothing to do with anything that yes
it is it period or Point Blank or is it
period point blank period you know Rosie
said you know I love Rosie always [ __ ]
up the expressions he goes you know I'm
trying to have a bunch of projects in
the fire
no burrs II irons in the fire
if your projects are in the fire your
projects are on fire which means they
are a steaming pile of [ __ ] they just
left because you know what the [ __ ] I'm
trying to say I don't know I [ __ ] up he
[ __ ] up expressions and then I [ __ ] up
famous people like we were at a Rangers
game he will never let me live this down
I said I we were at a Rangers game Oh
firstly go George Stephanopoulos George
Stephanopoulos
it's Josef innopolis he looked at open
it was Jeff Gordon the stock car driver
but they look alike but you do that on
purpose too
you're always doing like random people
you'll be like oh my god yep I do that
is a joke
I know that that's not him on the
bicycle no but George step I thought
that was George stepping on a Madison
Square Garden I knew it was a famous guy
okay young I know you did something I've
seen you want something things you
choose not to pay attention to
versus the things you choose to remember
it's so funny to me because it's like
who are we talking to and he said to me
after you had left this guy he was like
wow your husband knows a lot about
sports and I was like yeah he's a big
sports man he goes no but it's like
dates and you know different events at
different times and I was like oh yeah
where the [ __ ] batteries are in our
house it threw me out of the bus I know
where the batteries are in the house I'm
the [ __ ] guy who changes everything
what are you talking about I take the
[ __ ] garbage out I crush it I crush
it no that's not no if you [ __ ] tell
me that hey on next Thursday we're doing
something I'm not gonna remember that
[Laughter]
[Music]
I told you so it's like but still I
somehow I have to bear the the brunt of
your like you know forgetfulness and I'm
like remember that thing is happening
yeah will you have a drink
full circle Oh terrible yeah that's our
daughter's new thing let's say
sweetheart you got to finish your bright
you got to finish your vegetables
ah terrible all right I need to I need
to read I need to read some advertising
here
all right so verdict Mia am ia good
person yes you are a good person okay
all right so okay so you did something
nice for me so now you have to buy this
[ __ ] piece of art that somehow we're
gonna make money off of in case you know
I say the wrong thing on Twitter oh my
god I can't believe you said that thank
God we have this bucket of paint that
was thrown at this [ __ ] bedsheet and
is now hanging on our wall we can we can
take a second loan on off of this and we
can eat [ __ ] Alpo this week yeah but
if I get cancelled you're gonna have to
leave me because you'll be attached to
me to be like just to let you know this
artwork with oh is [ __ ] I don't know
the fact that they let eight hairy leg
white chicks go around just canceling
everybody out there it's just you know I
think that's beyond the privileged that
even I have dumpster fire alright
LegalZoom everybody LegalZoom you know
it's still early in the year but if you
run a small business you know 2020 will
fly by that's why you should use
LegalZoom right now to make sure you're
set up for success over the past 19
years
is legal some has helped more than 2
million Americans start their businesses
by incorporating former cooperating
forming an LLC and more but even after
your business is set up LegalZoom can
still help you out with a lot more
things like lease agreements change
changing tax laws and reviewing
contracts all play a part in running
your own business these are precisely
the kinds of costly hurdles they can
take time away from growing your
business don't let that happen
legal zooms network of independent
attorneys and tax professionals can
provide advice to address these things
in mula and you'll never get judged by
the hour since Legal Zoom isn't a law
firm go to legalzoom.com today and enter
the promo code bird in the box and check
out o at checkout for special savings
that's legalzoom.com code bar b you are
our Legal Zoom where life meets legal
all right now my god look at look who it
is Nia this is these are my favorite
[ __ ] people in the world
butcher bucks ah steak night that's the
first line I crushed it is any culinary
occasion more delicious parentheses
spoiler alert the answer is No talk
about your method for cooking a steak
well you know what I actually give it to
my wife she does I cook a hell of a
steak too but she doesn't cook that
often so I know when the steak comes out
I'm like I have at it yeah you like you
like what's that thing you know I don't
[ __ ] do this often but when I do was
that ad campaign I don't I don't always
drink toast sekiz but when I do I have
Dos Equis is that how it goes
mm-hmm I don't know what is that's right
that's right you're the most interesting
woman in the world I don't always cook
but when I do I cooked the [ __ ] out of
this steak she stole it from me you get
the skillet going you sear it on both
sides you finished in the oven then you
have a nice [ __ ] garlic butter Beth
steal it from you we do my pork chops
yes she did
you took a bite you dropped the fork and
that was it okay all right is that does
that like contractually [ __ ] obligate
that part do you a grill cast-iron
broiler how do you like to how do you
like it cooked what I like to do yes I
like to do I like to get a nice [ __ ]
skillet nice and hot you see her it on
both sides then you finish it in the you
know you have it in the oven and then
you take the [ __ ] thing out and then
you do a little [ __ ] you know well
not in a steak I really don't do that
steak should just taste fine after that
okay yeah and then I take it out right
and I take a big bottle of ketchup I
just dump it all over it and I stick it
back in the oven they had some turnips
if tenderness is the mark of an
excellent steak one cut is king and
that's filet mignon very difficult to
that's that that's a difficult one
because it's so [ __ ] thick you know
what I mean you don't want to overcook
it
you don't want to undercook it okay and
if you heats too high on that [ __ ]
right what's gonna happen is you're
gonna be well-done on top and in the
middle it's still gonna be [ __ ]
chilly willy I gotta agree with you I
like a bone-in ribeye to like a bone-in
ribeye and a nice bottle or two a
[ __ ] wined that's what I like with it
right on Buckland my [ __ ] pants
halfway through it you know saying
something inappropriate to the waitress
that's my idea of a good steak dinner
[Applause]
all right if tenderness is the mark for
an excellent eight one cut is king and
that's the filet mignon sure it's less
marbling than a ribeye but the texture
is unbeatable still missing the fat
there's nothing a that's nothing a quick
wrap in bacon won't fix and
right now butcher bucks gives you two
fillets and a pack of bacon free in your
first box this [ __ ] copy every week
man it makes me hungry
all meat is free of antibiotics and
added hormones that humanely rate and
humanely raised before they slaughtered
each box has nine to eleven pounds of
meat which is enough for 24 individual
meals or if you go to Dairy Queen all
the time you type of [ __ ] you probably
finish that in two settings right what
are you talking about here wouldn't
there you saying that I I binge eat and
then what I have puked behind the house
no but you do Benji no way don't what
what are you talking about I eat fast
that's different
I don't know I feel you go in on stuff
and you kind of like overdo it what's
part of being an American then it's a
whole shame cycle and then you're like
you know vegan for like five months yeah
it's called [ __ ] getting your [ __ ]
you know not letting the [ __ ] man
tits drop to the knees alright what you
know what Nina I I thought I was aware
of every issue you had with me I didn't
realize that this was another one can I
get back to [ __ ] butcher [ __ ] here
put your box each box thank I can
customize my box or go with one of
theirs
that's what people are gonna say someday
about when they're ordering a robot sex
doll I can customize my box or go with
one of them you just got the standard
[ __ ] right off the box either way I get
exactly what I want options like 100%
grass-fed and finished beef free-range
organic chicken I really feel like the
redheaded male sex doll at first will
not be a big seller and they will
discontinue it and then the price of
them will go through the roof you know
and then that's when I'll finally start
getting
I like to consider myself a rare
collectible
all right options like 100% grass-fed
and finished beef free-range organic
chicken my favorite my favorite heritage
pork what happened to the breed
he's B heritage breed pork man is like
Sears Roebuck knows the old George
Carlin book joke right whatever had
Maroma been wild caught Alaskan salmon
that wild yeah you don't know what those
fish are gonna do and bacon that's free
of nitrates and added sugar those
Alaskan salmon they come to they come to
town like [ __ ] Marlon Brando on the
motorcycle you ever watched that movie
The Wild Ones are the outsiders or the
hey we came to town let me tell you
something say that's that's it really
doesn't age well the way on the
waterfront is great and the other one I
could have been a palooka what the [ __ ]
is it called with portrait box you get
the highest quality of meat for just
around six dollars a meal and they even
have free shipping but he has two of
them he's got on the waterfront and
what's the other one Stella
yeah there's two of them no he has two
[ __ ] classics back-to-back palooka
which is what I am something like that
I think I'm doing [ __ ] pulp fiction I
love when [ __ ] Travolta calls when
Travolta calls Bruce Willis he goes
cause some palooka I loved it boiler
alert that's right
there's Travolta Ben J and he was taking
a dump with with butcher box you get the
highest quality meat for just around six
dollars a meal they even have free
shipping nation wild accept nationwide
accept Alaska and Hawaii oh you'll take
their fish but you won't hook them up
you can get two filet mignons in a pack
of bacon plus $20 off your first box
when you sign up now at butcher box calm
/ or use promo code / at checkout that's
to free filet mignons a pack of bacon
plus $20 off your first bucks just go to
butcher box com / / or use the promo
code bar at checkout I'm telling you
right now man you get any of this meat
all of this meats [ __ ] delicious I've
had all of it you steam saute a little
spinach with it or some green beans you
got your protein you got your vegetable
you wake up the negative full the next
day you wake up your stomach's nice and
flat right the next thing you know your
wife's thrashing in your own podcast not
because you're a jerk not because you're
not one of the greatest guys that ever
[ __ ] America ever produced it's
because she's envious of you and she
does not know how to communicate it
that's the podcast everybody yes you're
jealous of my my my wallpaper paint of
envy and jealous yes jealous jealousy is
you're afraid somebody's gonna take
something that you have envy is you want
something that somebody has so when
somebody looks at somebody else's car
and they go oh my god I'm so jealous of
your new car they're not they're envious
yes there you explain it to me yeah and
now he's fine smart I sound smart very
smart best messenger all right that's
the podcast I'm on my way up to
Vancouver have you ever been to
Vancouver Neil no and you never will
alright I don't know why you always blow
me off on though on the Pacific
Northwest
you know something yet you look really
beautiful right now yeah thank you
alright that's the podcast see that's
how you you know I didn't want to have a
fight after this [ __ ] podcast you
know I thought it was funny I just
thought in certain areas you went a
little bit too far you know the exit
interview you have to be careful when
you're talking about grizzly bears what
if people you know don't recognize that
you're [ __ ] around the entire time
huh and somebody has a fecking when if
it grizzly bears listening all right
listen to this music picked out by the
great Andrew femme
and then we have a bonus half-hour of
material a or podcast I should say from
a Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast from a number of
years ago and that's it ain't it did you
watch any of the Democratic
International pancake debate tonight who
is running for Democrats name name okay
let's warn Bernie Sanders Joe Biden I
feel like it's kind of not in the
conversation anymore
yeah I feel bad for Joe why I don't know
okay I just relate to him it's just like
old and you're talking and people are
sort of nodding but they're not really
paying attention to you which I will be
experiencing in four shows up in Canada
Oh Canada stop sending your comics to
court all right thank you so much have a
great weekend you [ __ ] and I'll tell
I'll see you on Monday what's going on
it's Bill Byrne it's the Monday morning
podcast from Monday February 20th 2012
and you're not gonna believe it am I
gonna start off bitching about these
[ __ ] headphones again cuz I know what
you guys are gonna say you like well why
didn't you buy some new ones you know
what I'm gonna say I was at Newark and I
was like you know what I gotta do my
podcast yeah this looks like a great
place to buy headphones the airport I'm
sure they have the top-of-the-line
and they're not overpriced whatsoever
considering I'm on the other side of
security so I did I dropped like [ __ ]
60 70 bucks on a pair of headphones
alright cuz I'm not spending any more
money what am i a [ __ ] DJ you know my
mmm adjusting the mixer levels here like
I got something to [ __ ] and say I'm not
alright I'm just a little mom and pop
podcast and [ __ ] store out here $70
headphones
the tax and the [ __ ] Airport [ __ ]
over right the airport fisting that
that's about right and I got him I
listen they sounded great on the
airplane they had this little [ __ ]
battery you put in him and then I I
click I flip a switch and then it's
supposed to make everything around me a
little quieter which it did which I
don't get how it does that you know I
got [ __ ] up here as people from
playing drums in that type of [ __ ] and
listening to ac/dc too loud and all that
crap and I asked these people about like
the Bose system about how to annoy scan
cyl is a ssin and cancel ization is that
a word canceling headphones and they
said well this is what we do we you know
whatever frequency we send the exact
opposite frequency and it cancels out
both frequencies and blah blah blah blah
so then you can't hear it so my thing is
if I can't [ __ ] hear it though but is
it still doing the damage you know what
I mean in the ear I just I just don't
notice it now because you've offset the
sound so I can't hear the sound but my
eardrum is still you know getting worn
down by the airplane decibels can
anybody answer that question for me does
that make any sense
like I know you've done a little parlor
trick here where now I can't hear the
noise that exists it's not like [ __ ]
earplugs you know what I mean like you
put earplugs in it's actually blocking
out the noise these [ __ ] things
they're sending out the exact opposite
frequency so then then I can't [ __ ]
hear but it's my eardrums still going
like right I prefer those little spongy
things that you roll up and you stick in
your ears and then you don't have to
clean them up for the next nine months
that's always great right and then you
put them in your pocket and it gets all
with that lint all over it there's one
for you ladies I'm speaking of ladies I
want to thank everybody for during the
flowers from proflowers.com
and I also want to give a shout out to
the people at the ProFlowers company
because they had no problem with my read
a few weeks ago they actually just
didn't like that I said the wrong
website
so if you listen to two weeks ago when I
did my filthy read of their copy you'll
now hear that I did a little insert
right where it's just me talking yes
take the face up your eyes the blahblah
and just go to proflowers.com and it
just goes right back to me ranting again
so how cool are they you know I don't
know if they'll ever appetize on here
again but you know what those guys are
cool I thought they were gonna be like
you know it'd be one thing if we sold
drugs okay we took we sell flowers all
right with these flowers of the exact
opposite of violent why would you read
it that way sorry um so anyways that's
that's what I'm letting you guys know
they they if I ever meet someone who
works at ProFlowers I'm gonna buy him a
drink all right
and don't even think you're just gonna
walk up to me with a little carnation in
your [ __ ] lapel and you're gonna fool
me all right you're not gonna have that
[ __ ] 300-yard stare that those
ProFlowers people have it's I'm
mistakable um anyways dude you should
see what the [ __ ] we bought for my dog
my dog has like separation anxiety and
like when you leave the dog alone it
like freaks the [ __ ] out you know like
oh my god this place is too big I don't
know what I'm gonna do it tries to jump
through the window is a closet the
woodwork so you know you've heard these
stories we tried to buy it cages or as
trainers call them Casas which is the
Spanish word for home and if you were to
look at these things you know they don't
look like a home they look like a cage
all right so I've been put my dog in
them
it's a goddamn pit the lovely Nia
everybody coming to the podcast let me
hit pause here and let me already talked
about Cleo
Cleo's new two-bedroom apartment we just
got her hold on a second hold on hold on
hang on everybody through the magic of
podcasting she'll be on in a couple of
seconds so anyways like I said to the
magic of podcasting the lovely Nia
everybody how are you hi how are you
great I am doing well what was with that
robotic hi how are you
I am fine I was just talking to them
about how we Cleo separation anxiety so
we've gone through all these different
cages and she's a pit bull so she's
broken out of all of them then she cuts
up her [ __ ] face
she's chipped a couple of teeth that
drives me nuts so we finally just buy
one that you just can't escape from and
it looks like a [ __ ] safe it's the
only way to describe it I never I never
liked it it was evil looking it looks
like that [ __ ] like you know those
Vietnam movies when they stick the
American GIs and like the little bamboo
things yeah yeah she just never really
does look like a mini prison cell yeah I
just didn't feel like she could stretch
or anything like that she couldn't she
could get up and turn around which is
what like they say is the requirements
is that they should be able to stand up
and turn around what she could do but
it's still small yeah I didn't like it
yeah so we just had a trainer basically
made essentially a [ __ ] lion's cage
for her it's the biggest thing I've ever
seen in my life yeah and I'm thinking
big yeah there's enough room for her bed
a whole nother section like she has like
it's like and when you're in New York
and you go from going from a studio to
actually having a one-bedroom apartment
yeah she's got the bedroom in the back
and then she's got the carpeted area in
the front is a little dog dish and some
water yeah the kitchen area some water
right little foyer for her to hang up
her jacket and you know what she does
she tries to break out of it again yeah
so it had nothing to do with how much
money I've spent on these [ __ ] things
I know no you don't because I do because
you keep reminding me of how much you
spent on it I know I am I freaked out
every time it [ __ ] happens at one
time she's fine she just got it's like
we got this thing's gotta be practicing
he just gotta be in it no I wanted I
wanted it to be big enough so she could
have her a nice big comfy bed in there
and Cleo basically has three stretches
for you yoga people she has down dog and
up dog and then she has oh no and then
she has the one when she lays on her
side and all four legs go straight out
all right
then she has the one where she stands up
and does the I'm a mad cat impression
my favorite one is when she sits down
and she just puts her head to the sky
and goes [ __ ] that's my favorite one
yeah she couldn't do that one in this
one now she can do it in there and you
would think we just took her from coach
and put her in first class yeah and
she's still acting like an ass because
she doesn't like to be confined she
doesn't like to be separate you know how
Cleo is she's very attached to us so
it's hard for her to just be away you
know I feel like he's needy or clingy I
feel like that father that just keeps
spoiling his daughter just keeps buying
her new [ __ ] keeps breaking everything
and no matter what I get it she's not
gonna be happy you know she'll be all
right
I just went before I came in here I just
made her lie down in her bed and she did
her little exhales driving me nuts so I
wanted to talk to you about no no I'm
not gonna get into that yeah let me just
think before I do that I gotta thank
everybody for coming out to my shows I
don't know if you noticed Mia cuz I know
you're out here just bacon cookies doing
your female stuff wow I just completed
if you wonder why I look so tired yet
satisfied I I just well II did a
whirlwind tour of the tri-state area
Wednesday night two shows at Vinnie
brand stress factory and New Brunswick
New Jersey charming
Vinnie brand Vinnie brand can I hear
Vinnie berry impression I'm Vinnie brand
my god
you had the right sound but you couldn't
come up with anything better like let me
hear your Frank Sinatra hi I'm Frank
Sinatra luck be a lady tonight
there you go never let her out of my
sight stick with me baby I'm the fella
you came in with luck be a lady tonight
you know what that songs about yes Belle
what is it about it's about a chick and
a dude and he wants to be once I have
some recognition
and a I'm treating you good there's a
being stop being a little that's that's
the medical huh see a metaphor for
throwing dice I mean that was like the
most dices the nickname for the dices
the ladies the ladies I didn't know that
I thought it was actually a woman but
old thing is it's [ __ ] both come on
come on you know I [ __ ] love on
clever they work by the time we got to
my generation Axl Rose was like yeah and
all those rappers I mean they just
[ __ ] they just really uh they just
[ __ ] and they went right down the pipe
with it yeah that's what you know the
gangster rap and and Guns and Roses
music that was like just like a Nolan
Ryan picture no action on the ball here
comes the heat or see if he can hit it
right sure yeah you watch sports so
anyways I want to thank everybody who
came out and and I think I deserve a pat
on the back that at no point did I make
fun of New Jersey for the amount of Bon
Jovi tickets that they still continue to
purchase home time here but Giants
Stadium still that's unbelievable what
about Bruce yeah but he's worldwide that
guy's national I mean I don't know I
mean there's always you know what's
great about this business is they'll
always be a country that loves you yeah
they always will be no matter how big
how small you want it to be huge and
probably want it to be America if you're
an American I guess but you know
what's-his-face Hasselhoff huge in
Germany gram all right Jerry Lewis got
his recognition in France
much like the jazz players of your ilk
right
and by ilk I'm
mean african-american you know what
happens to me every every year during
Black History Month this is what happens
there's always somebody some white
person it's just me and another whitey
right and they always have to be like
dude what why why do they gotta have
like a month you know do we get a month
oh god well it's kind of true Nia we
don't get a month that's right that's
right we don't get a moment this Tom
broke a month yes oh yes we we
definitely need like a month dedicated
to the struggles of white people yeah
yeah well you know what I want to eat on
that white folks you know what I want to
do organizing some [ __ ] and maybe it'll
happen for you hmm where the great white
leaders campaigning for it oh right
there in the Klan well tell me about
some white struggles Nene can't think of
any of course you can't does that mean
there isn't any what about all those
Irish guys all those Irish guys came off
the boat let me explain let me finish
no I wanna talk about potatoes yeah
hearing about the shits in high school
maybe two black people in my high school
class in Atlanta Georgia which fault is
it I'm gonna kick you why did you move
to the whitey land that's like a fight
in the why deal and why the nice private
because she went to a private school
like [ __ ] Tupac and then he comes out
yo I'm hard and [ __ ] look at my tattoos
he didn't go to private school you went
to an art school please it's different
that guy had a tutu in the 8th grade
look anybody gets shot and can still
give the camera the finger I know about
your background again the point it was
rough talking about you know slavery and
all of those inevitably inevitably there
was some kid in class who's
regurgitating their grandparents and
there are their parents you know feeling
like they're not getting enough you know
I don't know praise for what white
people went through or like what about
the potato famine a potato chip question
not the same as people being in I wasn't
I wasn't talking about that in the
middle passage it's not the same and
I'll also point out sorry everybody
I don't know if that's a completely
equal Harrison also it's not a who
suffered more contest all right I'm done
I was talking about when the Irish came
over around the Civil War and they went
to that little Ellis Island out there
they needed guys to fight in the Union
Army
so the second they landed they say
listen you can sit here and get some
venereal disease and smallpox or you can
go fight for the Union Army and after
them [ __ ] signed up landed on Ellis
Island signed up and then immediately
was shot in the forehead by a [ __ ]
cannon down in South Carolina all right
I'm just saying everybody's got this
[ __ ] but not this stuff you know what's
[ __ ] up is I was actually gonna defend
you and you so [ __ ] said here
sticking your mitt in the face of whitey
now now you got now you got me with my
[ __ ] backup all right I'm just saying
it's always funny cuz there's always
somebody somebody was saying to me this
weekend I go and I find he's give me a
month I know they get 29 days this could
you just give him the [ __ ] month you
know what if they had white
entertainment television people wouldn't
like that like white people really give
a [ __ ] about be et oh Jesus what are you
talking about trying to have fun here
nobody nobody said that what you're
doing now is that me said white people
are a-ok and my buck you guys are great
no I gotta like I actually love my I get
annoyed when people get those two
conversations that white people bring up
during the year that bugged me one is
why is there a Black History Month which
is the obvious question is because if we
didn't bring it up you wouldn't and not
necessarily got it out of being an
[ __ ] it's just not what you focus on
right you know you're in your world yeah
you wouldn't think exactly so and then
the other one is whenever the n-word
subject comes up well you guys say it to
each other all the time how are you
gonna get mad and then they go how come
folks so then why can't I say it and
then I always go well why would you want
to say it you know and then wait and
then one time they they did a
documentary on that and then somebody in
the documentary goes I think white
people are just mad cuz there's
something that they can't do and that
was the one where I almost took my flat
screen and [ __ ] jammed it in the
toilet and flushed it that whole [ __ ]
okay as much as we don't understand
Black History Month that whole [ __ ]
thing that oh I'm white therefore the
government gives me a USA Today and a
bag of cash every morning it yeah that
ain't happening all right that's one of
those deals
I think example of you know there's a
lot of white people out there it's like
even Eminem who is so seeped in hip-hop
culture and like completely accepted in
hip-hop culture because he's a great
lyricist and rapper he doesn't use the
word
so if Eminem is not using the word what
makes you think that like Joe baloney
sandwich can use that word
[Laughter]
so anyways at once a year I have that
conversation once a [ __ ] year
somebody they're not racist you [ __ ]
listen then that racist they're doing
what you're doing which is what looking
out their own heads that's what people
do like the world is from their couch
alright and when it doesn't make sense
to them they don't stop and go oh hey
wait a minute let me try and turn this
around and look back at my couch they
don't [ __ ] do it and you know what
neither do you with your little [ __ ]
rant about potatoes I wasn't even
talking about that I was talking about
these you know that you imagine that you
keep [ __ ] you're trying to flee you
know they're out of vegetables somebody
said the funniest [ __ ] about the potato
famine hi everybody starved it's like
you live on an island why don't you go
fishing you [ __ ] morons
I ate it no more potatoes what are we
gonna eat I don't know have another
drink it's one of the funniest [ __ ]
things I've never even thought of that
but the thing is though it is I mean as
much as it's a [ __ ] island I mean
it's not the size of like Gilligan's
Island it's bigger than that so I guess
you'd have to get on your little [ __ ]
bike cuz that's all they had they don't
have cars in Europe except for like
their stuff the international bankers
you know and then they get the police
escort going down the street talked
about when we go over there yeah and it
wasn't until I got this Sweden they have
it yeah it's so disappointing when
you're in other countries and they just
have that we like the regular one yeah
my voice is a little sharp from
screaming I usually do a better siren
sounds sexy Oh would you like me to do
that come in to the bedroom sure let's
just go
so anyways well speaking of other things
black this week Whitney Houston just out
of curiosity is that gonna come out on
DVD at any point or later that was like
the greatest [ __ ] funeral the funeral
is better than the Grammys it was it was
pretty amazing you really felt like you
show up and do something really weird
and scream at an old white man thank God
what was that about
is she trying to out Lady Gaga Lady Gaga
just for weird and it's not even art
well you wait wait wait till they both
fall off and then they have to do that
that the duet Nicki Minaj and then Lady
Gaga like when Mick Jagger and David
Bowie got together just saying dancing
in the street and they were like Rhode
Island Worcester South they started
rubbing their asses together yeah I
don't mean this in a homophobic way at
all that was that was the gayest thing I
think we can all admit even gay people
can admit that was extra extra fruity
that was no but the whitney houston
funeral it was it was like a real
funeral it wasn't like you know the
michael jackson memorial obviously was
sad and he had performers but it was
more like star study
it was like you know the Kardashians all
posing together holding programs and
[ __ ] this one was like how - teens went
to the wedding the the memorial the
wedding I mean the funeral yeah Michael
Jackson yeah there was it was all kinds
of celebrities there you know it was
like the highest ticket in town
and then this one really felt like cuz
they had they make like a Michael
Jackson like Laker jersey like a one-off
Michelin s was it like that I don't know
did he go out like Elvis what do you
mean just like completely exploited
right into the [ __ ] ground
[Music]
one of Mo strongly criticized artists of
all time well get into that later Nene
white people stealing from [ __ ] that
he stole all that [ __ ] from them is such
a crock [ __ ] in this is why I say it's a
crock of [ __ ] because if he was black
what he would be considered was he's
he's carrying on the tradition but if
somebody white is into that music then
what it is is you're stealing all right
now I'm not saying that the label didn't
give those guys you know the label they
probably didn't even pay Elvis forget
about the [ __ ] artists who originally
black artists who originally wrote that
song but I've been around long enough
Nene that I know that half those [ __ ]
people who are saying that Elvis stole
from them they stole this [ __ ] from
somebody else you ever listen to that
[ __ ] music blues music how many the
turnarounds half the [ __ ] lyrics like
cuz if she won't I know her sister will
that lyric is in like 50 different songs
how many of them were backdoor men I'm
telling no I'm telling you and it into
the stand-up arena when I did that
[ __ ] circuit there's there is some
originality there but there's a lot of
thievery going on so I would I would
question I'm just saying
Elvis is the original behind the music
guy he basically like he lived every
[ __ ] cliche before it was a cliche
that thought he was bigger than life and
the guy's belly was full of [ __ ]
advil before they even
vente where the [ __ ] he had and he died
on a [ __ ] toilet you know it like
younger than me yeah all right
people still parade through his [ __ ]
house and have dumb conversations near
his grave there's a souvenir shop across
the street they've turned him from
everything into a cuckoo clock to a
[ __ ] spatula
that's Priscilla yeah his [ __ ]
managers stole from him and everybody
just says he's a piece of [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] thief I mean I thought he had
respect for the music and he just did
his thing he liked the music people and
all people people who bet your bottom
will say he's a thieving piece of [ __ ]
and that's like they sat down listen man
I saw some colored people down the
street they're doing this stuff dude I'm
gonna take it we ain't give him any
money
all right you're talking about a guy who
just flew around and ate peanut butter
and banana [ __ ] sandwiches okay and
came out with those stupid Batman
bedazzled gay capes you know do you
think he really had that [ __ ] some
broke kid from like he had the foresight
to do all of that come on he got [ __ ]
raped declined his record yeah yeah yeah
and then he takes the fall he takes the
fall I'm just look I'm not saying that
they didn't take that music and I'm not
saying that those people didn't get
[ __ ] everybody gets [ __ ] in the
music business okay and they got stepped
in was there racism
abso-fucking-lutely but to sit there
just literally look at Elvis like there
was no talent there is horseshit all
right all these [ __ ] people they have
black frame glasses and they're goatees
once a year thrashing him I really get
all these Bill Russell look-alikes have
had it the assault and pepper afros
leave the King alone pick up somebody
else all right what else what do we got
here what did I want to talk about our
job as black people is to keep you down
to earth to make sure what happened
all those years ago in this color we
gotta keep reminding you of how evil you
are to keep you in your place Miami
no I am I am I'm an evil white man
III do a lot of the white man [ __ ] or an
angry white man yeah yeah but I has
nothing to do with black people no I
know you're just angry it just kind of
fell out of the sky you saying you know
something actually somebody said
something to me this weekend and I was
like I really wished Nia was here so you
could have heard it and said like Billie
there's been like a changing you know no
you seem like you let some stuff go like
you you know you I don't know you were
laughing you were actually you know
talking to people after the shows and
blah blah blah blah blah blah and I was
like you know I can I can you please say
that again with that same level of
conviction and can I record this and
then send this to the lovely Nia so you
can quit breaking my balls over here we
got to the biggest [ __ ] fight this
weekend I did say that I wasn't gonna
bring it up I say yeah I've been making
fun of Kobe's wife on on the you guys
will see it it's my clothes
that's my clothes and on the stage there
it's my clothes and bit the signature
piece I like to save my next special
mm-hmm what do you do you call me up and
you mind [ __ ] me like I'm being too mean
I wasn't mind [ __ ] you I was there
talking to you about we've been talking
like I said we've been talking about
this subject for months ever since you
started doing it on stage you know I'm
gonna you know spar and debate with you
about it because on one hand I feel
we're right before I do is special I
might say you diabolical yeah I just
said I'm an angry [ __ ] psycho can you
take one hit can you take one shot to
the liver all right you have this way of
like yeah you know that really funny
part in your act
what's up with that well I don't mean to
I'm not trying to mind [ __ ] you or mess
with your career your you know your
jokes of people [ __ ] love and what
makes you so great but you know talk
about I get it yeah yeah he was she was
trying to suggest that while Kobe was
out there scoring 6,000 points a game
and raping [ __ ]
he's got acquitted
we gotta quit it raping [ __ ] up and
found like five different guys semen in
that girl I know I really wasn't good
look yeah that really wasn't a good look
in her panties Nia whoops not even in
her in her pictures even [ __ ] hoes
herself down
she's even washes it's disgusting yeah
yeah all right can I continue yeah so
she was sitting there trying to suggest
that his wife is was at home holding
down the fort raising the children yeah
on her hands and knees scrubbing the
kitchen floor with the toothbrush her
big move every day was which mall am I
going to her job was to watch I
guarantee you her job was to watch the
nanny watch the kids
it smells icky take care of it she's
totally in shape Nia I know yeah that's
not a mom supermodel that's not a mom
okay you you're a mom and you have
multiple kids okay I see that Chuck my
act
my mom she never did drugs in her life
doesn't remember her 30s that's a mom
yeah it's just a [ __ ] blur you mean
it's not being like not having like a
six-pack after three kids on vacation
girlfriends knowing what the hottest
shoes out there are no stranger raise
our hypothetical kids strange raising
them either but I fully intend on like
looking like oh absolutely
oh you will stay in shape I'll [ __ ]
fill the bedroom out in the garage for
you to sleep in daddy for you buddy and
that's exactly what you should say
it is completely [ __ ] unacceptable to
be like while I'm married to him now or
I'm married to her now eat on either
side and then just let yourself go and
have that big Pelican neck you know and
any guy has to sit there in order to
bleed the lady he's got the guys with
the big beard
and to try to keep your 32 inch waist
you keep pushing your [ __ ] jeans down
you know and you got that giant like
your shirts pushed out so far you
starting to see the skin in your belly
right when your belly button is facing
the floor like a bombardier looking for
targets and Dresden that's when you know
you're gonna [ __ ] lose some goddamn
weight so anyways when I was trying to
tell you I should wish you came out we
did one of the stops on the whirlwind
tour of the East Coast was we did the
theater at Westbury in Long Island and
it was in the round and yeah I opened
for Dane at Madison Square Garden oh it
was in the round and sitting there the
place is going [ __ ] nuts and I was
going like and you know Danes just
[ __ ] you know sitting there you know
eating celery sticks like not even
nervous and I'm like dude he's like
what's up man I go what the [ __ ] and he
just laughs and he goes it's ego just go
he was brilliant he goes it's for
theatres he just broke it up because you
facing this way that's a theatre you
face that way it's a theory and they
just combined and but obviously you're
not like circle like turning in circles
the whole time you know how do you know
when to turn around I can't explain it
it takes about six minutes to figure it
out
okay and then once you then you start to
[Music]
you know there's a way you can cheat all
the way to the side of one stage and
have your back turn to them and then
you're seeing three-quarters of the
crowd and then you just try to keep like
a mental thought in your head you know I
haven't looked this way in a minute hey
let's give that let's give them one over
here it was fun I was [ __ ] around
going you know what's great about this
is if I start bombing over here I can
just f [ __ ] no it was awesome and it was
it was like built in the 1950s so
everyone from Frank Sinatra Sammy Davis
jr. The Doors yeah the whole when they
still had Keith Moon I'm staying on the
stage going [ __ ] Keith Moon was on
the stage Jim Morrison was on this stage
and when I was up there halfway through
it I realized how he meant doubt I'm not
kind of positive of this did this
stand-up special when I was a kid that
really
stuck with me as far as like his
interaction with the crowd and his bits
and how funny he was and he was silly
but he was really good at using the
f-word he was really good at cursing and
like he had a couple of classic ones
like you know he was really like manic
anyway what's your name what's your name
put your name askew three [ __ ] times
you know he would do [ __ ] like that and
he had the one we're down that special
was the one where he was wearing the
suspenders and he bent over doing some
bit and on the back they came off and
Lily went up in the air and landed on
top of his curly hair and then the whole
crowd laughed when he stopped he says
wait a minute he goes what the [ __ ] just
happened and the place went crazy and
like he was [ __ ] destroying and I
don't just years later all of a sudden
you're there was was one of the coolest
nights I mean that's right up there with
with give me Carnegie was Carnegie but
that one was like I love that [ __ ] just
like going to an old sports stadium you
know what I mean
and going oh that's where the Red Sox
choked you know all the old stadiums was
where the Red Sox chokes all the new
ones are better except for last year
with their [ __ ] chicken and beer and
the goddamn you don't couldn't yeah you
could have played for the Red Sox last
year in September they were getting
hammered and they'd eaten like chicken
wings and [ __ ] not being racist I know
this is Black History Month I didn't
really mean it that way
well any time you bring up chicken
around a black person like it gets all
[ __ ] weird like we'd all don't eat it
I don't get that we went to Frank Pepe's
pizza so how was Frank Pepe's [ __ ]
insane so it really is cuz you kept
going on and on about this play supposed
to be the best best what I earn America
yeah America yeah and it really lived up
to the hype yeah okay
it was insane and one of them ones that
we got was this one that had clam clam
oh yeah which I was right with would
have thought was disgusting was like
when the signature ones it was [ __ ]
delicious the next time I go there I
would definitely get their classic plain
like they don't have a sauce they fly in
like an organic tour mate like tomatoes
from Italy and they just crush it on the
top of it and put it near it's insane
it's the thinnest goddamn crust then
there's another place down the street
and that's the one that allegedly
Sinatra used to order from
so I don't know so there was it was sick
it was like this little strip in New
Haven
it's called Frank peppe's PEP ' yes if
you're ever driving down in New York or
just live anywhere near there you got to
check it out I would definitely suggest
going there like we did on like a
Wednesday afternoon or a Thursday
afternoon cuz there's nobody there cuz
on the weekends it looks like Bon Jovi's
playing there in Jersey speaking of
which I got to get to some sort of
advertising here I almost called you
Cleo Wow all right let's start with uh
gamefly.com everybody do you play video
games sure we are game flies the video
rental system that delivers video games
to your door will deliver those
sons-of-bitches right to your door who
likes that better than gamers right you
sitting there with your legs falling
asleep you finishing your game right you
order it up like Howard Hughes they
bring it right to you and now to your PC
games right to your PC alright
I don't know how much easier this has to
be Gamefly has over eight thousand
titles to choose from and works with
every system out there and Monday
morning podcasts get a 15 day free trial
ooh that's right 15 day 15 days of free
games
I haven't said 15 days 15 days of free
games weeks by going to WWF like ombre
be you are are give it a try it saves
you money no late fee no late fees how
the hell does that work yeah keep it as
long as you want you know just whatever
you think about giving it back mails
directly to your house again you get a
free 15 day trial you goto gamefly.com
slash bar and you start playing the
video game saying guys do me a favor if
you if you play one that you really like
you know I fly a lot and I kind of you
know I did that one time when I flew to
Australia I played Tetris like for eight
hours straight and I was just having the
time of my life because I hadn't seen
this is one like those old school games
first started coming back and I was like
it just took me back to the arcade when
you go down there and your parents
didn't want you to hang down at the
arcade because that's where the riff
raff you know
at least in my little white town that's
where they were at yeah bullying kids
yeah so if you guys you know if you
stumble onto one now just know that the
last one that I played was grand theft
auto part three and I don't uh what are
you looking at nothing why you turning
on my phone over there and just because
I was you were talking we were talking
about games and I wanted to download a
free game onto your iPhone just put in
there I mean I didn't even I was
watching at a buddy's house I was
watching the Knicks game yesterday and
he's like you should have your phone
locked in case you lose it then someone
can't call it I was like alright but now
it's like a pain in the ass because I
set it down for two seconds because I
have it on immediately immediately so
when we get off the air I got to give
you my passcode card because I just
realized what if I do a faceplant and
you don't have your cell phone
oh well so we have a new advertiser for
this week and I cannot say enough about
this product for hockey players out
there you know what it's really [ __ ]
rude that you're playing with my phone
is I'm trying to [ __ ] myself out of
here you love this product so yes as you
people know I took up playing hockey in
the wonderful month of August in 2010 I
got all this stuff out there right fall
down I feel like I'm landing on it you
know I got all the equipment so when I
fall down the ice Nia it feels like I'm
landing on a mattress it's phenomenal
when I first started playing all I had
was the helmet in the gloves and you
know you remember that like three days
later I would wake up but I look like
somebody beat me with a bamboo Reed okay
I think those just those bruises
somebody hit me with this yes yes but
but the only thing that's such since
then is the only thing that hurts is
there's nothing worse than taking a puck
off you skate [ __ ] kills I can't even
that's an indescribable pain it's like
stubbing your toe times 9
all right and they actually said if you
take a slap shot at a hundred miles an
hour to your foot it's like get shot in
the foot with the 22 caliber yeah so
it's always like why isn't there any
sort of protection down there well
somebody's finally done it
skate fender calm they actually sent me
a pair of these things there's these
little plastic guards they're clear
plastic you put them on 19 out of the 30
NHL teams already have players wearing
them and actually tried them out the
other day because I was concerned like
I'm already slow enough I don't need to
be adding weight to my feet you can't
even tell they're on they they weigh as
much as socks you can't even tell and if
you get hit with the puck I swear to god
it feels like getting hit in the shin I
mean it's like you know you got hit but
you can barely feel it and you can keep
playing and so anyways all the NHL guys
are starting to wear them I'm telling
you this company's gonna blow up if I
could invest in it I would cuz I this is
one of the ones either Nike or Reebok is
gonna buy it out because it's brilliant
like like I was sayin 11% of all
injuries in hockey are foot related so
you're taking that off the table I mean
think about that
like for most of us our NHL dream is
over and you got a real job I don't know
about you guys but I don't need to take
one to the foot and the next night go
limping out on stage with one loafer and
a clown shoe on you know what I mean it
makes no sense
put him on go be the first guy to have
him out there and you watch cuz
everyone's gonna be like what are you a
fan right and then they're gonna take
one of the foot and they're gonna be
crawling off the ice and you're gonna
take one you're gonna keep going all
right and then eventually they're all
gonna be wearing I mean you'd be like
dude I called it what did I say so this
is what you do you go to skate fender
calm they got two different they got the
they got one that I like $69.99 and they
got ones that 7990 and I definitely
spend the extra ten bucks it's totally
worth it
I know you're like oh that's kind of a
lot of money can you put a price on your
foot you know do you want to be that old
person hobbling down the street with
that little metal half a cage that those
people walk with get off my property you
don't want to do it if you still want to
be able to cross check somebody with
your goddamn cane
when you're in your 90s I recommend
these things and that's all you do you
go to skate fenner calm and click on the
size that you want and when you get to
the page where it says apply the coupon
you just type in my name bill burr no
spaces all lowercase B I ll be URR and
that's it and order them up and that's
it you know
I guarantee anybody's ever taking a puck
to the foot is gonna is gonna win unless
there's some macho [ __ ] and they'll
take one more hit and they'll be like
alright you know what I think I'm gonna
wear those alright let's get back to the
comedy what do I want to talk about oh
here's something - I bought this any
ac/dc fans out there this is just gonna
sound like a back to back commercial but
this isn't Mark Evans the original bass
player for ac/dc
I've been listening these people since
you were about two years old and I
always wondered like what happened to
the first guy that's always been like
the first bass player that's always been
like my question whenever I watch behind
the music you see some huge band and
it'll just be like you know the
guitarist had a baby and decided to quit
the band you know and that's when Jimmy
Page joined and I always used to think
what the [ __ ] ever happened to that
other guy you know and I actually wrote
a movie script about it and I couldn't
make it funny enough and then years
later that dude with the part down the
middle did a movie that was essentially
what I was trying to write are you still
with me on the podcast you read in the
book so anyways Mark Evans Mark Evans
the original bass player for ac/dc wrote
a book called dirty deeds it's already
in paperback I know it's been out
probably since the ending of last year
I'm tearing through this book it's a
whole new perspective on the band and
it's also like as he's really honest and
he kind of shows like there's a couple
I'm not gonna ruin the book but there's
a couple things he writes he goes yet no
no to people who are in bands I'll just
say one thing that he said if you have a
bad show and you're having the band
meeting right after the show a good
thing don't be the first guy in the band
to leave because the finger-pointing is
gonna start and if you're out there to
defend yourself it's gonna it's gonna
come on to you but like he has a
couple chapters in there Nia if I can
just get you to look at me at this point
bond stock bonds go yep what I love
about that that's the exact same sort of
dirtbag [ __ ] that you do on Facebook in
myspace but it didn't exist back then so
you actually just sit down and write a
letter
he's like send me a photo get one of
those Polaroid cameras can't wait for
those bikini pictures preferably less
yeah can't wait for the three yeah right
that doesn't sell the book it's called
it's called dirty deeds and if somebody
knows Mark Evans if I ever go to
Melbourne or whatever the hell he's
living at I get it I got it I got some
free tickets for him without a doubt um
I always put that out there I put I put
it out there for Ric Flair I'm hope one
of these times one of these legends is
gonna show up but I'm all the way up to
the chapter where he's about ready to
get fired and I actually read a little
bit of it and it's absolutely like you
just like this guy's are like really
describes like like the power of ac/dc
when he talks about like they used to
start their set with that song livewire
and how like he would just be playing
the bass line and then Malcolm would
start playing the guitar and then when
Phil and Angus kicked in like they would
just blow the roof off the place in
front of like like 20 people and when
you're really into a band like that's
the big thing like oh my god I want to I
wish I saw them before they hit and he
describes that period in the book like
you know from a guy because I far as I
know
Angus Malcolm none of them have ever
read a book written a book so to finally
hear a guy talk about what is it like
when you're when you're in that band and
it just [ __ ] lifts off like that he
said like their record label guy when he
first saw him when they went to London
when when Angus and Phil Rudd kicked in
during that song like his [ __ ] jaw
was on the ground like oh my god this is
gonna be these guys are gonna be [ __ ]
huge and I remember talking to somebody
who worked for Aerosmith and when ac/dc
opened up for him like Joe Perry was
going nuts watching him and he was hit
and Stephen gone watch because it was
actually the second or third night he's
gonna do the he called it the frying the
bacon thing we saw ECDC you know when he
lays on the ground
what kills he doesn't miss a note and
like I guess Joe Perry was like freaking
out and you know was just saying these
guys are gonna be [ __ ] huge and they
got that new DVD out that I've been
talking about that Jim Breuer was
telling me about going I was like yeah
I'm gonna watch and Jim goes no you have
to come over my [ __ ] house in
surround sound and you have to sit there
in the dark and you have to watch this
[ __ ] he's a dude he's gonna new he's got
a new 90-minute set does not curse once
and kills as hard as he's ever killed
yeah like it's like some I can't even
describe like when he we were on the
anti social network tour together last
last year it was really it was really
inspiring I mean I'm always gonna stick
to my filthy guns
it just is Who I am but I have
unbelievable amount of respect for the
fact that that heat that he's doing that
cuz I'm like that guy is he's gonna have
that this second wave of Jim Brewers the
[ __ ] on top of the original wave and
he's gonna go yeah he's gonna go to a
whole nother uh you know you can be
going to like a Buffalo Sabres game and
they're gonna be also you know high you
know hyping the upcoming Jim Breuer show
that's my prediction all right and with
that let's get to the letters for this
week lastly you know I was bitching
about Valentine's Day you know I always
teased you about you know how we go out
to celebrate our relationship except I
pay by the way how much fun was it going
out on the 12th it was great it was nice
quiet yeah romantic yeah there was none
of the hype we went to a really nice
place
I'm not gonna lie it wasn't actually
cheap but I can't imagine what that
would've called we would've been
standing outside yeah you know you and
your little glitter dress looking at the
other girls and their glitter dresses
going do you like my glitter dress as
much as her I should have got mine in
poufy shoo-shoo colors so anyways so
I've been bitching about the ladies on
this thing right like what do you guys
do and they're talking about this steak
and a [ __ ] day yes yes
yes all right I like it I'll tell you
when you're in heaven when not only can
they I can't say it yeah when when
they're when they're proficient in both
of those categories because there's a
lot of people out there they're gonna
say all right staking a [ __ ] day and
one of them isn't gonna be up to snuff
and there is there is a prevailing
attitude amongst women that they are
just automatically good in bed because
they're there and there's the prevailing
attitude that men don't know what's
going on we don't know what's going
where anything it is we're just happy to
be at it's a privilege which is why this
lady who says the Valentine's Day this
is this is from a lady she said hey Bill
I heard what you were saying about women
and Valentine's Day and how we don't buy
our men gifts and we expect the whole
day to be about us well here's what I
did for my husband
by the way I'm honestly not trying to
sell you anything he goes she goes I
bought him the Liberator wedge ramp
combo set what's that you might ask
actually know about this from the Opie
and Anthony show they refer to it as a
bedroom as bedroom adventure gear it's a
set of cushions designed to help you
achieve more positions during sex as
well as deeper penetration so no we
didn't go out to dinner no stupid cards
were exchanged we simply stayed home and
[ __ ] all night same joke on that you
douchebag I love you bill
go [ __ ] yourself I like this girl yeah
but you know what's funny about that
yes she's patting herself on the back
she bought something for herself
it's for both of them no it isn't I
don't need deeper penetration that's for
you
that is it we'll see again that's the
difference what is the difference she
know the yeah I'm not saying that that
guys don't satisfy their women properly
that they that their dick isn't big
enough I'm not talking about that I'm
talking about how she's patting herself
on the back like she went out and bought
this guy the NFL package for next season
like she actually went out and bought
something for him she didn't at the very
least she bought something for them but
the real thing about that that's for the
woman so he can hit it at that angle
that you like so he can hit you
spot so he can get in there deeper guys
you don't appreciate that I'm not saying
I don't appreciate it and I'm not saying
it's not a great invention but what I'm
saying is she's acting as though like
this was some sort of a sacrifice that
she basically bought him something that
would get her better dick and she's
patting herself on the back for it it's
[ __ ] ridiculous I think it's clever
it is clever because she's acting as
though she did something but she didn't
see this is that this is the thing about
that is the genius of women is you guys
act like sex doesn't feel good for you
to you act like you you guys allowing us
to have sex with you like you don't want
it and like this is like you like waxing
a floor and it's just a big [ __ ] pain
in the ass you know that is like
celebratory of their relationship as
opposed to like the typical dinner it's
like it's about our intimacy it's about
our connection so why don't we get
something that will enhance that yeah
but this is the thing I got to go out
and buy you like some necklace or some
do I get to wear it I got to take you
out to dinner
celebrate and I pay for the whole
[ __ ] thing it's all about the guy
going out spending money on you getting
you [ __ ] that you want and it's the
pressures for the guy to show his love I
also get to you oh I know what white guy
who can dunk a basketball all right
let's stop talking about the exceptions
I'm talking about the [ __ ] rule here
all right okay you know what I'm saying
yes I do okay all right there we go tap
it out white why do women act like sex
doesn't feel good to them what do you
know I couldn't tell you you don't have
any insight I can't keep this going all
right oh god it's such a chore like
maybe the next one I was making men will
be complaining about that I don't know
but when I was making fun of Valentine's
Day this weekend some girl in the crowd
was going like you know what I said well
what did you do for it and she goes she
he got to hit this and points to herself
yeah
what can I just show up and be like hey
you get to suck this lady never you
never get to do that right I don't know
this is what it is this is what it is if
guys could ever stop being such [ __ ]
[ __ ] and giving it a well that's why
women women don't respect dick is
because it's so easy for them to get it
if you'd stop giving it away if every
guy would just start the day and [ __ ]
rub one out right world would be a lot
more peaceful at least until 2:00 in the
afternoon by then your balls fill up
again start getting competitive why his
cubicle bigger than mine I mean know
what I'm saying here it's just it's in
order this it's just one of those things
that balances it out right
I can choke slam you on the floor and
you could cut off the sex and that
balance is out but it's illegal for me
to hit you but for some reason it's not
illegal for you to cut off the sex and
that right there people is what's known
as the tipping point that's how you lose
you have beautiful cheeks slap
non-relationship advice okay bill I need
your help I've been making how do you
say that looks like Satan it's a Chinese
American dish that looks like Bonjour
bon jour from scratch for some time now
it's calls for soy flour but I think
that I may have an allergy to soy I've
been substituting chick pea flour for a
while but the consistency is a little
off any help would be great yeah
why don't you just go with regular white
flour that your body can't process
nothing tastes better than [ __ ] real
sugar white flour
you know don't drink diet soda just
drink less wait a minute like a chef
person could help them out with this yes
that's what's funny about this Nia you
just totally I'm not a chef I was she
probably to tell him what the [ __ ] to do
with it I was on my way to say moot
Sorella sticks here and you're like wait
a minute but you don't know anything
about this
any help would be greatly appreciated
ladies and gentlemen once again once
again a female showing their comedy
instincts oh [ __ ] yo I know it's a big
tragedy it's a big tragedy how people
view women in comedy and it's all guys
fault
it has nothing to do with the thousands
of horrific sets come on Nia look at it
doesn't look at empathy sometimes
empathy helps sometimes it doesn't help
I'm just talking about his stand-up and
I think there's a bunch of hilarious
people out there Chelsea Peretti's one
of my favorites yeah Chelsea [ __ ]
hilarious she loved chelsea peretti one
of my favorite bits the last five years
when she said she was she was a fat guy
comedian I asked her bad about the other
day they said they edited out of her
special which sucks why because that's
what editors do they're like what makes
this awesome
remove it um I'm just saying if somebody
said white guys can't dance am I really
gonna get mad at that am I really not
gonna honestly look at myself and admit
that I'm part of the problem then I'm
not one of those people you know if I
ever wanted to become a better dancer
just let that roll around your head
without laughing right if I ever wanted
to be a better dance India what would
what would make me a better dancer to go
out and [ __ ] learn how to do it and
do the work or for them to lower the
[ __ ] standards pull yourself up by
your [ __ ] bootstraps
bring in and bring it move on no I'm not
saying that they don't get [ __ ] and
that there's not it's not unfair but
like this whole straight across the
board thing where people think that
they're ready to be on [ __ ] that they're
not ready to play key really you're the
next one in line you know all right
whatever from Argentina
another one from Argentina Argentine is
a great cut is a great country men what
this is what happens when people write
in a second language but I can't get my
[ __ ] here you will find the reason why
the ac/dc crowd was so incredible they
sent our link the reason is that
Argentinians in general are soccer fans
but in
sanely fan not funny
I don't know I can't even read this
stretches read this in an accent soccer
fans sex desire or performance is
directly proportionate to their
correspondent team performance in the
league oh so if your team leads you
loses you don't even want to [ __ ] or do
you hate [ __ ] your woman and blame the
loss on her it's crazy but it's true in
the video you will see the entrance of
the team to the field each Sunday the
majority of the Argentinian teams have
an entrance like that because people are
[ __ ] up and I can't even read this in
one of your podcasts you mentioned where
you find a good steak steak spelt like I
want to kill a [ __ ] vampire here in
Argentina we have the best meat in the
world it's insane the meat quality I've
had the possibility to travel to many
countries and I've never tastes better
meat than here is like the cheese for
the French or the tacos for the Mexicans
I guess that you imagine aren't it
Argentina like if we live in the sand
hunting for a food like National
Geographic no I don't you [ __ ] no I
don't see that works both ways they
always say Americans are ignorant you
know what I mean
you guys are egg you dare whole [ __ ]
idea of us is ignorant is ignorant of us
like first of all like you guys are
[ __ ] brilliant like I'm gonna go down
to Argentina and everybody's gonna be
looking through a telescope and it's
gonna be proficient in like calculus
give me a [ __ ] break you just like me
alright you're trying to get a sandwich
you're trying to get laid you're doing
what the [ __ ] I'm doing alright I'm done
reading this I get it you guys are
[ __ ] awesome fans and I would like to
go down there I would like to learn your
language and I would like to have you
[ __ ] Kobe beef okay
they just keep bringing you racks and
racks and racks of meat yeah I don't
like this first of all I never feel
worthy of eating like that like I just
conquered some cash yeah I don't lobby
used to go up to that one right up the
street
yeah and they
absolutely loved it I've never been any
of those restaurants yeah I was never
into that that style why I don't know I
would just rather just have like the one
steak yeah I eat too much when I go
there the guy comes up it's like the
three musketeers you know and they come
up and the roast beef ham and [ __ ]
something else I will have all of that
bring on the winches
all right blasted a girl in the face and
self-defense
need advice all right let's first see if
this was self-defense oh gee oh gee here
we go hey Bill I need your help I punch
my best punch people can you proofread
your [ __ ] hey Bill I need your help
I'd punch best friend's girl I have past
six months is this another guy from
Argentina
this better be a second [ __ ] language
people are you I've actually found
someone dumber than I am I have passed
six months for the past six months I've
lived with my three best friends until
one of them decided to move on move
their girlfriend who was used to mommy
and daddy
who's used to mommy and daddy buying her
[ __ ] in with us all right so you have an
attitude towards her that isn't good at
first I was okay with it because it was
less money okay so basically he's living
in this flat and one of the guys brought
their girl in and at first he didn't
mind because it was uh it was cheaper
but after two weeks she showed her true
colors she acted like a [ __ ] that
traded periods with blue whale this is
definitely a second language this is
from Borat she complains that the food
we bought was too cheap or the living
room furniture was too cheap and tacky
looking that was not the worst her and
her best friend argued non-stop from
morning to night or would have loud
drunk makeup sex oh that's her in the
boyfriend the most horrible thing she
would do was if one of her roommates
would tell her about herself she would
tell her best friend and then hotel or
something about itself what the [ __ ] is
with these emails this week
anyways so this girl is annoying him he
puts up with it until the Super Bowl
night my condolences by the way thank
you
go [ __ ] yourself if you're not serious
yeah every everyone had left the place
because there was a campus party and I
did not want to go this is when the
problem happened about a half about at
halftime show the girlfriend walks in
[ __ ] house with about four of her
friends this is an American rightness I
stand corrected we are stupid high they
sit in the den with me being loud as
[ __ ] then they all start singing along
to Madonna during the halftime show I
just want to take a beer bottle and jam
it in my ears just before the second
half is Sartre I informed them that I
want that if they want to stay they have
to shut the [ __ ] up the girl makes a
racial comment towards you I'm assuming
I call her a whoring [ __ ] next thing I
know she is on me punching me I push her
off but she sinks her mr.eddy teeth in
my [ __ ] arm and won't let go so I had
no choice but to blast her in the face
her friend
pick her up and carry it to her to her
room and she's knocked out cold
this guy really got you got all of that
didn't you you I did you push her away
with the forearm that she had the teeth
in and then bring her immediately back
to your body as you drew your fist back
and who I am is that I went down
cuz that's tight quarters if she's
biting you anyways well I rushed to the
ER to get eight stitches in my arm Jesus
Christ that's amazing to be able to do
that with human teeth you know this is
brutal flash-forward two weeks and
nobody in the house will talk to me then
one night I get off work everybody's
sitting in the living room with College
counseling intervention style they tell
me that my girlfriend is scared for her
life and I need to go to anger
management or I have to move I look at
my friends who know me all my life that
I would never hit anybody even a woman
unless I had to in disbelief so bill
should I go to anger management to
appease him or just ignore her cuz I'm
sure it's how moving out of the house
Thanks yeah just move out just move out
it's not worth it everybody all the
other roommates know this girl's a
psycho too but she's such a psycho that
they're like afraid to say yeah look
what somebody's biting you to the point
that you have to get stitches I mean
what are you supposed to do now late
hearts sweetheart stop it please women
should not hit men because it's not it's
not this is by the way this is if
everything he said was true yeah so if
everything you're saying is true I would
just I would just move up yeah just get
away it's a bad situation
walk away be glad that she didn't
[ __ ] call the cops they always got it
they always got to get the last could it
could have been worse just just move out
just move out quietly don't have any
contact with that guy in his girlfriend
anymore don't hang out with them if
they're gonna be if they if everyone's
hanging out and they're gonna be there
don't go just don't let you know it's
annoying me with this you know it's
annoying me with this is if it went down
the way this guy said it went down this
girl got what she deserved and someone
like this the last thing they can ever
handle in life is when they get
something that they deserve so right now
so what she has to do is she has to get
another the final blow you know I'm
gonna get you in trouble I'm gonna tell
on you
I'm you're gonna go to anger management
and you have to go through the pain in
the ass of having to move and then she's
gonna sit there all kunti as he moves
out like doing that [ __ ] yeah
and it's making me want to hit her
there's a good one should I kick my
neighbours ass hey Bill loved the
podcast no that's East Coast
oh that's why people [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] is a podcast um I need some advice
on what to do about the gut this guy who
lives in a few houses down for me I'm a
third-year college student and I live at
home my parents moved to go live in the
state above mine you mean north
and I currently reside alone while they
are trying to sell the house a few
months ago I was driving home coming
back from a gym and while I was driving
in my neighborhood I saw this guy step
in the middle of the road about 20 yards
from my car he was yelling something at
me but I couldn't hear what he was
saying I slowed down and stopped my car
right in front of him and he came to my
window and told me to get out I was
totally confused and thought I'd run
over I thought I ran over his cat or
something also I think he just moved in
because I never seen the dude in my life
so I rolled down the window and asked
what did you say he goes I'm gonna kick
your [ __ ] ass get out of the car this
guy's probably in his 40s and has to be
around 510 is that is this me 250 pounds
That's not me
I'm 21 63 200 I do CrossFit and I
wrestle occasionally at another gym I go
to so I get out of the car and I'm
standing there trying to figure out what
the hell is going on the guy starts
moving towards me so I take the
initiative and take a step towards him
we end up being an inch from each other
and he's trying to do some alpha male
[ __ ] by just staring at me but I have
the height advantage so I'm looking down
at him at least 10 seconds go by before
the guy goes how fast do you think you
were going back there I say I don't know
probably around 30 the speed limit my
neighborhood is 20 and I know I wasn't
going that much over then he goes I'm
not gonna have my children playing in
the yard if I know [ __ ] like you are
driving like that in the neighborhood
after he said that I saw his wife and
son were a little off to the side of the
road once the word [ __ ] left his
mouth I was [ __ ] pissed I wanted to
just tackle the dick and put him to
sleep in front of his wife and kid to
teach him a lesson but I pussied out and
just apologized to him and said that I
was really sorry sorry and it wouldn't
happen again the guy then gives me a
[ __ ] little smirk and turns around
and says while walking away with his
back turn it better not or you know what
will happen oh yeah
yeah you definitely should have kicked
his ass you should have kicked his ass
yeah do you realize what a good do you
realize what this kid did he's such a
[ __ ] gentleman he could have kicked
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out and he saw his wife
and kid that it would have been
emasculating yes dad is Superman he sits
there you know it is it's that little
smirk yeah that [ __ ] smirk I bet that
[ __ ] steals from work yeah I bet he does
sorry dude that's the first time I
really had to walk away you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you should have kicked that guy's
ass but it's a good I don't you didn't
but he definitely hasn't come in this
many rights now after that that [ __ ] I
wanted to explode I mean the guy totally
disrespected me so I get in my car and
drive off and the story wrong I couldn't
get this [ __ ] guy out of my head I do
it I can't get out of my head I'm gonna
actually fantasize that I was there and
he did that what I would want to do I've
already you know what I would [ __ ] do
I would wait till he was alone don't do
this [ __ ] don't do this but I know what
you just want to get it get the guy
alone and be like hey what are you gonna
do now huh what are you gonna do now
just get right in his [ __ ] grill and
have him back down or I would almost do
say the guys say hey listen man just
come over the car and just say listen I
just wanted you to know the other day
that if I wanted to I could have [ __ ]
stuffed you in my trunk tied you up like
a [ __ ] pretzel and ass raped you in
front of your [ __ ] wife but I chose
not to okay cuz I didn't want your son
to know what a little [ __ ] I can't
say it [ __ ] he has four that would have
been homophobic either I wouldn't even
be talking about gay people that's such
a [ __ ] [ __ ] move yeah and it for
some reason but but I'm put up no then
that's what you say maybe do it like
Columbo just say listen man I gotta ask
you something cuz I'm six foot three I
CrossFit I wrestle okay and just looking
at you
I know I could tie into a pretzel I know
I could do it if I wanted to but the car
that you had I just want to know what
what is your background you know cuz you
know I'm a real competitive guy you know
if you got some sort of martial arts
training you know I would love to have
you once we don't you come down to the
gym sometime when your wife and kid
aren't there so I have to feel guilty
when I [ __ ] you up and close both your
eyes with this one and it's friend over
here it's not over though I know because
that's what's happening now this is what
happens when you do the right thing in
life okay when you know it eats away at
you you have to make peace you have to
make peace and and you got to tell
yourself the lie that some day this
guy's gonna get his and you know what he
doesn't guys like this don't get theirs
oh that's smart I think this kid really
painted a [ __ ] picture I think this is
driving me nuts
he goes I couldn't get this guy out of
my head a week went by and I was still
thinking about that [ __ ] too I would
think about this guy 20 years from now
two weeks later I was driving home from
school and I see the guy rolling his
garbage can out to the curb I slowed
down to [ __ ] under 20 and I know this
because I look down at my spit Thomas
pedometer I pretend to stare the guy
down so I look at him and he looks at me
and yells slow down Wow
now when he said that I am [ __ ]
raging I wanted to stop my car and do
some ground-and-pound on his face yeah
this kid knows what he's doing this
isn't wrestling like this kids doing UFC
[ __ ] but did I know I just drove off
like a [ __ ] the next day I talked to my
friend about it about what had happened
and he said that this guy said the same
[ __ ] to him if he said it he would have
put him on his ass I know you dude you
know what I would have done he told me
that if he says he's going to kick your
ass then that's a threat so you can
defend yourself don't listen to your
dumb friend he's saying you won't get
arrested so a few months have passed and
I'm still thinking about this [ __ ]
every time I Drive by his house fast
forward to yesterday and I'm I'm biking
in my neighborhood listen to an AHA and
I hear a honk from behind me so I pulled
my bike over to the side of the road
and it's none other than the same dude
in his Ford f-150 driving along and he
looks at me and gives me the middle
[ __ ] finger Wow now granted I was in
the middle of the road and didn't hear
the guy coming because I was listening
to music but still the middle finger so
I bike home take a shower and try to
convince myself to walk over the dudes
house and confront him but after a
couple minutes of pacing I just decided
to wait it out until the [ __ ] does
one more thing I mean I don't want to
get arrested so my question is what the
hell should I do
I mean every time I Drive by this guy's
house now I want a [ __ ] veer off the
road and ran my car into the middle of
his living room and the advice would be
good all of my friends think I should go
over there but I want a second opinion
you can't do anything to this guy unless
unless he puts his hands on you this is
just one of these things but you can do
to him what he's doing to you this guy
has an insane temper so uh you know I'm
not advocating legally so you don't do
this but like I don't know what next
time you know if you see him out in the
yard or something this is what you do I
have a great idea do you have any
friends who are really good mechanically
why don't you take your credit card out
go down to the [ __ ] auto store or
what it will go online and buy like one
of those [ __ ] train horns and have it
installed in your car and next time you
drive down the street just be sort of
zigzagging down the street just to get
this guy to be [ __ ] you know getting
all like what I [ __ ] the second he
starts screaming you lay on that [ __ ]
horn as loud as humanly possible and you
blow out his eardrums that's what I
would but then again then no one douche
like this he would say that I have
permanent hearing damage you know what I
think you should do maybe because I'm a
female and I'm all about a cycle revenge
okay psychological warfare what should
you do what should he do I think when
the husband is not home I don't know if
how if he knows his schedule or whatever
he needs to go over there when the wife
is at home and be like listen you know
I'm so sorry about that time that I was
speeding I really you know but your your
husband seems really upset I'm really
not trying to be like that I would never
do anything like that in women are like
Oh
she knows her husband is a psycho I mean
she could turn around and be like yeah
you shouldn't do that either but I have
a feeling she's not like that
and he can just go over and just make
nice and be like the sweet kid that's
helping out with the husband and he's
like sitting there sipping tea with the
the wife you know I don't know you know
it's a great thing to do and then [ __ ]
the wife no no he should [ __ ] his wife
he should [ __ ] it you should play with
this kid in the backyard like the toss
the football around with him be more
like this there's nothing like just
start giving them the finger listen this
is deal all you got to do is just give
him the finger give him the finger right
back
cuz this guy thinks you're a [ __ ] right
now so all you got to do is you know you
can just yell back just say you know
just give him the finger yell back at
him when he's in the driveway I would
like swerve at him and then swerve back
just [ __ ] with the guy he's my mean just
do that once because the next time he
might have like a video camera but I I
just don't want to get any I don't get
any you know what if I was in that
situation dude you know what I would do
yeah Oh a Morning Quarterback
look when I was in that situation with
that other guy right yeah but the last
place we lived and I didn't [ __ ] with
him because he was an old guy I just
didn't [ __ ] with him and now we found
out he has dementia and all his [ __ ] so
I'm psyched
I never yelled at the guy you know what
you do now you know what what really
diffuses angry guys like that or makes
them even more angry it's just laugh at
him just keep laughing at him laugh at
him give him the finger and just keep
calling them tough guy all right that
tough guy anything to anything you just
keep calling them anything that is
remotely alright there Chuck Norris
anything you want to say to this guy
that will bait him into hitting you this
isn't really [ __ ] this is a great
question and I don't want to get in
trouble if some [ __ ] goes down so you
shouldn't do anything sir wink wink wink
this guy's such a dick I know I always
say you know [ __ ] with somebody's car
was like a [ __ ] move but this guy's
such a dick and he has like such a oh my
god dude how many times you thought
about throat just choke slam and that
guy ran into the hood of your car
repeatedly nobody if you just said it
really calmly you said it calmly with
sort of a smile on your face you come
off like a [ __ ] maniac yeah that's
true if you scream that at somebody you
just sound like you're quoting like you
know Hulk Hogan or something right yeah
let me tell you something brother come
this Saturday but a Benjamin Russell and
a scraping all right overrated
underrated underrated female friends I
just broke up with my with my lady my
girlfriend she was a great woman but she
didn't live in my city and there was
some other issues and it was not the
right fit even though I was completely
honest and open this girl once I knew it
was over
I broke up with her the nicest way I
could nevertheless it's hard to walk
away from an otherwise great girlfriend
and I totally felt guilty about it when
I mentioned this to some of my guy
friends they were like oh sorry bro
bummer let's go get drinks which was
nice in its own way but women I am
friends with in my life immediately
looked in on me and showered me with the
degree of validation support and
encouragement without ever questioning
my decision yeah I would think it one of
them would at least give you a handy I
was their friend so whatever I did was
right and I was automatically an awesome
person it was a little disorienting
because I felt like they were they
weren't really looking at any of the
circumstances of the largest behind my
decision but it felt really good wow
that guy just generally likes the
company of females I thought was gonna
come around and then they felt bad for
me and one of them blew me you need
female friends man
alright overrated female friends um I
don't know what it is about females that
are that they are programmed to behave
in a way that that grants their friends
blanket validations without question or
hesitation
it's called loyalty but oh come on you
guys don't you guys have loyalty
in certain areas come on I know a lot of
women who say I don't have any female
friends I can't hang out with women
Thank You Patti and blah-de-blah suck I
don't know any guys who go I don't have
any guy friends
I find them too petty they childish yada
yada yada I know guys that I like that I
know they prefer hanging out with girls
because they want to [ __ ] know because
they like talking about stuff and
whatever and like doing activities you
know I've heard this from a straight man
who do you know like that I know what
straight guy like that like all his
friends are checked and they kind of do
that whole blanket oh everything you do
is awesome oh I can't believe that
person broke up with you it's so sad let
me take care of you
oh he's a mama's boy I'm talking about a
guy talk about guys how he isn't guys
guys don't just hang out with women they
don't maybe he's not a guy's guy yeah
you wouldn't take him and I'm not saying
he's gay I'm just saying he's like a
mama's boy grew up around women probably
doesn't like when probably doesn't like
ball-breaking probably finds that
childish yes yeah exactly
okay he's not good at it and he always
loses and then he gets mad he gets mad
and his ears turn red and everybody
makes fun of it who feel like I'm on the
playground let me go hang out with what
you know all these women who replace my
mommy
let me guess does he like to cook too
but if this is what yeah I know this guy
all right
but if this is what their support
network looks like I'm getting back to
this thing it all of a sudden made a lot
more sense to me that this is how girls
rationalize and perpetuate horrific
decisions that make no rational sense
buying a nickel for every time I was a
victim of chick logic I would have a
huge goddamn pile of nickels on the
other hand I would make a lot more
terrible decisions too if every time I
made one of my group of if every time I
made one every one of my group of
friends validated me thank you to my guy
friends for calling me out of my
[ __ ] so says a guy he sees he sees
uh he's
I definitely lead with sympathy rather
than well what was your part in this
whole thing we definitely don't you end
with [ __ ] talker II talker II when they
leave the room hey I just realized I
have a couple more reads I have to do
amazon.com has been a great thing I
don't know if you heard about this Nia
if you're gonna go to you you do it too
if you're gonna go to amazon.com
I'm not saying you have to Nia there's
no pressure this is the low pressure
sale but if you're gonna go there and
buy some stuff uh-huh just go to
billboard comm click on the podcast page
and you click on the little Amazon link
I've already done it you've already done
it I have and it's easy and you can do
it too you click on it and then you go
then if you want to buy something you
buy it all right and I'll get credit
they give me a little kickback and 10%
of it I send to the Wounded Warriors
Project how great is that great
organization hey and by the way where
I'm actually I'm doing my special in DC
coming up and my publicist we're trying
to hook up some of the troops out there
yeah great idea
but I'm gonna try to make it over to
Walter Reed in some of those places yeah
so please it took it's a great cause it
really is a great cause and something
that you know it's just one of those
things it's like it's like rescue dogs
you kiss you can't mess with that like
why wouldn't you go down and help others
you know I just compared human beings to
rescue dogs I'm the worst I'm just
saying it's just something that you
can't you can't you can't [ __ ] with that
whatever your feelings are about that
whole war on terror
you don't oversell it Nia I'm just
saying when you know what to do Porter
men and women over there it's it's hard
over there who among us would do what
they do exactly that make I'm sitting
here in pajama bottoms it's almost 11:00
in the morning and I am the furthest
thing from a hero
you look up antihero in the dictionaries
a picture of me with my pajama bottoms
on all right stamps calm everybody this
site is blowing up
do you hate going to the post office
sure we all do even going down to buy
stamps even using their auto
made in machine you always end up behind
some guy who's got to figure out how to
weigh his package and I don't know what
I'm doing you know Freddie twelve
fingers trying to figure out how to do
it
well this is the deal stamps.com he sign
up with these guys they send you a scale
they give you all this paper you can
print out stamps at home if you're
sitting I got a mail something ooh I
need stamps it's a mere click away at
stamps.com I printed out all these
stamps I've mailed DVDs I'm weighing my
stuff alright it's awesome I wear a
little mr. McFeely speedy delivery hat
no I love it and I'm a grumpy old man
who does not like progress I love dead
state stores that just sold him I'm
sorry I just thought of a big thing I am
how much ham you know roast beef anyways
with stamps watch calm as I said you can
buy and print official US postage using
your own computer and printer you can
print stamps and shipping labels for any
letter or package because they give you
that scale the instant you need it then
the mailman comes to you house and they
pick it up you'll never have to go to
the post office again phenomenal um what
up I'm a busy guy I don't like going
down that you know mean eeeh I'm on the
road all the time last thing I want to
do is get in a car and go on another
damn journey I want to sit here in my
boxer briefs pay the man and go right
back to TV and play a couple of games
that I got a gamefly.com that's right so
right I'm really gonna be like this
stock car guy you know they they start
putting the hats on yeah but listen to
this we got a special offer right now if
you go to stamps.com this is a special
offer from my listeners only but use the
last name barbie you are are for a no
risk trial plus you get $110 bonus awful
offer that includes a digital scale and
fifty-five dollars with a free postage
55 bucks that's
yeah that's like three months of postage
for the regular person all right won't
cost you a damn dime so go to the stamps
calm before you do anything else click
on the radio microphone at the top of
the homepage and you type in Burpee URR
to get you 55 dollars in free postage is
plus $110 bonus
oh no that-that-that's is included in it
so they gave me another 55 dollars worth
of stuff and a free scale or whatever
the hell it is I don't know it's a damn
good deal it's a damn good deal and you
know what this was a good deal another
podcast an hour and 25 minutes
an epic podcast for this week I hope you
guys that's it is that it for February
no this week I will be at the Comedy
Works in Denver and it's coming down to
it it's coming down to Annie I got this
special down and I think it's gonna be
special somebody and a good friend of
mine for a long time who if I if I name
this special I think I'm gonna name it
this I'm not gonna say what it is yet
because I'm not sold on it all right
and I really like it and last thing I
want to do is put it out then everybody
goes stupid I'm gonna call it alright
whatever
alright that's the podcast for this week
go [ __ ] yourselves don't take any [ __ ]
and that guy the dude there with the
psycho neighbor I'm telling you just
shake your head just laugh at him
nothing good is gonna come from actually
doing something to that guy I don't
think you'll get any satisfaction if you
figure out what his insurance deductible
is and you keep doing damage to his
truck that's just under it I really
don't think that you'll get any
satisfaction are there some day you'll
feel guilty if you do something like
that
alright that is the now don't do that I
think I think I think you go mental on
this guy you can't go physical that's I
would just drive by and I would put the
car in neutral as you glide by just beep
in the horn
love your truck you putting on weight
guy you look adorable I would be the
most that's what I would do I would be
absolutely obnoxious what if he just
loaded up your cliff he was out in the
front yard and you just kept driving
back and forth with your friends in the
car and just kept driving by his car
guard just keep waving at him what do
you say Chumlee order 20 pizzas have it
delivered to his door there's all kinds
yeah just [ __ ] with his world no no you
will get no satisfaction out of doing
that take the hide no none we fed by
that Jesus Christ alright see you later